et ce soir je crois que tu as quelque
chose à dire à inès kevin est venu
exprès pour te dire quelque chose ce
soir
alors il va pas te demande en mariage
que si tu sais pas si c'est déjà fait
bien sûr tu mais je crois qu'il est
autre chose a dit le divorce est
foncel tarbes à lui dit alors tu fais
pas un truc mignon on n'aime pas ça chez
noa tu sais tu as yet patins profiter
tout le monde à tout le monde d'être
merci d'avoir une invitation
ben c'est pas de moi qui ai les clés ça
fait un petit moment maintenant que tu
veux des papiers dans ta vie je n'arrive
jamais accès m donc aujourd'hui je
profite de ce plateau pour le faire
cécilia non non non non non attendez
pourquoi s'être fait des trucs comme ça
tu va regarder dans cet écran la laverie
j'en profite
c'est ce soir que je te mets des
paillettes dans ta vie
[Musique]
je ne lui veux
à la salle